[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday March 14th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
The Fallout from the collapse of Silicon
Valley Bank is still taking shape but on
Monday customers of svb and the
crypto-focused signature bank got some
welcome news the federal government said
it would ensure they have full access to
their money here's President Joe Biden
on Monday morning your deposits will be
there when you need them small
businesses across the country that
deposit accounts that these Banks can
breathe easier and knowing they'll be
able to pay their workers and pay their
bills
and their hard-working employees can
breathe easier as well now as Regulators
look to reassure the public that
America's banking system is secure
startups that were the bulk of svb's
customers are looking to make sure
they're better protected in case
something like this happens again
joining me to discuss the changes that
are in the works is our Venture Capital
reporter Berber gin hi Berber thanks for
joining us hi Zoe excited to be here I
want to take a step back first we heard
a lot about Silicon Valley Bank's assets
versus liabilities and the Panic that
led to its downfall but can you explain
what specifically was going on within
startups that led to this collapse sure
so during the bull market it was very
easy for startups to get money from VCS
and they were depositing a lot of that
money into Silicon Valley Bank and that
basically led to a huge rise in deposits
for the bank but once the market turned
and startup funding dried up you saw a
very quick reversal of that phenomenon
where startups began burning through
cash and those deposit amounts were
going down very quickly and it was those
fast withdrawals which essentially
pushed the bank to try and raise cash
and sell some of its Bond Holdings at a
loss that was what sort of created the
perception that
the bank wouldn't be able to meet
withdrawals which sort of created the
bank run on Thursday in the first place
so now that some of that is dying down
in the wake of all of this there do seem
to be calls for Founders to change how
they deal with their assets where they
hold their money what are their
investors suggesting that they do
absolutely obviously this crisis has
made Founders aware that they need to
think really conscientiously about where
they Park their cash so investors are
advising Founders to start a opening up
a lot more bank accounts and not storing
all of their cash in one single Bank
provider and investors are also
counseling Founders to make sure that
the cash that they have in those banks
are insured the big problem with Silicon
Valley Bank is that startups they
weren't thinking twice about the risks
of parking millions or tens of millions
or hundreds of millions of dollars
in One bank account where they were
going well over the sort of 250 000 that
the FDIC insures Founders are going to
be thinking a lot more carefully about
their banking practices now and I think
that speaks to just the general
instability and vulnerability that
Silicon Valley finds itself in I mean
even a week ago this is not something
that any founder or investor would have
been worried about they would have been
worried about being able to break even
finding a path of profitability finding
a way to raise money
the fact that these startups are
spending time now making sure that their
banking practices are safe and you know
are designed in a way that'll protect
them against vulnerabilities in the
banking system I think that really
speaks to the changed environment that
the industry is in right now
you cover venture capital for people who
are less familiar with it often these
investors are working closely with
startups why didn't they raise these
questions earlier because a lot of
startup Founders don't necessarily have
Financial or banking backgrounds they're
tech people a lot of investors took
Silicon Valley Bank for granted I mean
this was a 40 year old institution that
was seen as the linchpin in many ways of
the startup ecosystem they offered all
sorts of financing packages that were
really tailored to the startup ecosystem
and a lot of venture capitalists also
banked with Silicon Valley Bank a lot of
those funds actually had their money
Frozen in Silicon Valley Bank over the
weekend and so I think Venture investors
thought that Silicon Valley Bank was
this infallible institution that wasn't
vulnerable to collapse I mean when you
think about what is vulnerable in the
startup ecosystem you usually think
about the startups themselves you don't
think about
these sort of long time publicly traded
heavily regulated institutions Berber
there was a lot of discussion online
about svb as things were unfolding I
want to talk a little bit more about the
role that message boards social media
and just this tight-knit startup
Community played in spreading the news
about svb can you tell us a bit more
about that a lot of that came on social
media it came over WhatsApp group
channels signal Channels with Founders
and investors just a sort of real-time
updates and rumors that were circulating
of investors telling Founders to pull
money that really created you know this
level of paranoia and fear that
precipitated this bank run it is
important to note that you know a lot of
venture firms they were more
conservative in the advice they gave
Founders like as late as Thursday
evening Coastal adventurous for example
they're a very well-known VC fund they
weren't telling Founders to pull our
cash from Silicon Valley Bank they were
telling them it's important to diversify
but they were staying away from the
suggestion to just basically pull your
money out so it's interesting to think
about the different dynamics that are at
play where some VCS were a bit more
Machiavellian they were like there's no
risk to pulling your money out where
others were a bit more idealistic and
and those are the ones that actually got
burned at the end
to any of these VCS then to take
responsibility or feel any Fallout from
this collapse I think there's actually a
lot of frustration within the VC
Community about how certain actors
handled the news that Silicon Valley
Bank was essentially raising cash and
selling some of their Holdings to try
and Shore up their balance sheet you
know I've talked to venture investors
who basically say this is a failure of
the tech community that Venture firms
should have more conscientiously worked
together to try and stem the panic and
assure their Founders that their cash
would be fine and work harder to save an
institution that I think everyone
thought to be extremely important for
the startup Community this is all
happening
Evil Within we're seeing layoffs at Big
Tech firms we're seeing you know
difficulties from startups raising funds
before this happened can you just give
us a sense of what the state of the tech
sector is right now it's extremely
vulnerable it's important to remember
that this bank's collapse comes during
the worst Tech downturn in over a decade
it came at a time where
funding for startups has dried up and so
I think the events of the past few days
just the fact that an institution that
Founders and investors thought would
endure for so long disappeared in 36
hours that's extremely jarring and
traumatizing for Founders and investors
the bank's failure also just speaks to
some of the unpredictable consequences
of the change in the macroeconomic
environment in the past year like the
banks collapse essentially came from a
high interest rate environment
that was part of the reason why some
customers were moving their money out of
Silicon Valley Bank in the first place
and it comes on top of you know less
than six months after ftx's collapse
which was another unexpected event that
similarly like wiped out a good chunk of
the crypto industry which is obviously
very Central to the startup ecosystem so
very fluid situation I'm sure we'll be
talking about it more and more that's
our Venture Capital reporter pervergen
thanks for joining us Berber of course
okay that's it for today's Tech news
briefing but a quick reminder before we
close the show we want to hear your
questions about generative artificial
intelligence AI programs like chat GPT
Microsoft's new Bing search or
mid-journey and we're going to answer
them on an upcoming episode do you want
to know more about how these AI programs
work what they're capable of or maybe
what this latest wave of AI developments
could mean for how we live our lives
email us a voice recording with your AI
question to tnb wsj.com or leave a
voicemail on
415-439-6482 we look forward to hearing
from you
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign